[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello everybody and welcome to another
iron lords podcast first look at a game
called shalaga now
this game is uh
it was very unique and it was uh given
to us uh to uh to take a look at so uh
when we took a look at this game we
wanted to um
to to see
what exactly it was about uh this is
from the developer andrew
simmons thomas uh now
the game is basically about uh you are a
druid who is going around and trying to
defend the last of the trees in your
area and you are just getting waves and
waves and waves of lots of different
people attacking you or i should say
different monsters popping up from the
ground underneath you
it is a very simplistic game that has a
lot of potential and the reason why i'm
saying it's got a lot of potential is
because
i found myself after wave five or six
not really thinking of anything else
other than
the
waves and the monsters and the placement
of where to put the seeds
and where to do
lots of different things like that it
took me uh not too long to kind of sit
there and go through the process and
eventually kind of work my way into
um
into uh the
into the map and figure out better
placement of the trees and and uh
knowing where the monsters are going to
come up so it kind of uh pushes them
into into one location now
the thing i really thought was cool was
um the music was was a heavy metal music
so if you're really really into heavy
metal music you can listen to this it
was really really well
uh well done composed uh it was taken
care of very very beautifully the um
the artist suite our history of the of
the
of the game itself was very like i said
simplistic
but after a while you didn't notice the
simplicity of the actual um
the the graphics around so it worked out
very very well uh if you're looking to
uh to pick up a game where you can go
and uh you know kill a couple hours um
just uh mindlessly just killing some
crazy demons trying to uh to take your
trees um you can definitely uh pick up
this game and uh you can check it out so
thanks again and uh this this video here
is just a little bit of uh you know the
the the content that i ended up being
able to pick up and i think uh you know
it would be great if you took a look at
it so thanks again if you have any
questions or comments please leave them
down below and uh if you're looking to
see the iron lords podcast check us out
on sunday and uh myself is you know me
it's pete snaldow here i am monday to
friday on twitch on my channel so if you
are looking for uh
looking for that go ahead and do that so
thanks again and have a fantastic week
bye everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this
so
[Music]
[Music]
you